[Music]
here we
go God I love this
[Music]
book see I was telling the truth who's
the weirdo
now not a real F don't worry I have it
all under control
I got everything under
[Music]
control are you
okay I said personally Hope You Dance as
well as you
dress there's only one way to find
[Music]
out you and I we're not so different
agent
our it'll help hold
[Music]
on the book is phenomenal sweetie
but what happens next it's called a
cliffhanger mother Ellie it's called a
[Music]
copout whoa hey there's a cat in
there oh my God you're Ellie freaking
Conway author of ARG series Elly
Conway I am such a fan oh yeah what is
it you do Espionage would you sign my
book here we go
I love this
book come
[Music]
on who are these people real life spies
why would they care about me because
you're a goddamn fortune teller
Ellie what you wrote in your new book
actually happened and you Kicked the
Hornets n you didn't even know existed
I'm in some really big trouble
Mom oh so now you're experimenting with
drugs I want all assets on them now I
need her to write the next
chapter God I hate that
cat with
sus
[Music]
it's time for you to meet the real agent
Argy oh my God oh my God oh my
[Music]
God
he